tonight we have some breaking news this  morning there are some new plans to  build another arena it's a pretty big  project on the south end of the las  vegas strip oakview group has announced  on twitter it's purchased 25 acres of  land near blue diamond and las vegas  boulevard this is kind of near the  outlet mall down there bloomberg reports  it's a three billion dollar  entertainment and retail project it  would include a 20 000 seat arena and a  hotel and a casino that land is also  slated for a high-speed rail line  station between las vegas and southern  california talks bringing the nba there  that was initially where the raiders  stadium almost was also built so  we'll have more on that coming up later  this morning very interesting maybe wu  nba team here please come to las vegas